hey Zoey how you doing so this is Zoey
my daughter we're doing like a secret
life of dad because she's never seen
sort of when dad goes away to talk about
movies where does he go so we got some
questions let's kick it off go ahead
how are you most like your character
well I'm small um I'm white and fluffy
and I have very big teeth and I like
carrots this has got to be one of your
favorite characters that you play yeah
it just seemed like you were having a
lot of fun you know what snowball was
such an amazing character to play
because he has levels see the beauty of
snowball is he's hurt
you know he's hurt because he had owner
had owner and the owner left him the
owner just left him straight and when he
did that that kind of mess snowball up
because he felt like the love and
emotions that he had were were for
nothing they're all going your
daughter's very good question first of
all I happen to be an all pet person
because I like cats and dogs and
anything that's just walking around and
being furry and funny I'm gonna say I'm
a dog person I think I like dogs better
I can pick anything pterodactyl a
pterodactyl
I want a pterodactyl I think it'll look
real cool if I walk outside on a
pterodactyl is standing on my shoulder
you know you're a pet guy and and we're
peppy what do you think it is about the
pets that just people find so comforting
that they love it so much that so many
people have that there's no complexity
no pets are letting you down
for the most part nobody's betraying you
nobody's forgetting to pick you up from
the office because you asked them to
nobody's nobody's bringing their drama
into your life it's all just love you
understand how much I love Staten Island
wait how much do you love step back so
then that means that we both love Staten
Island so look take all your love for
Staten Island right put it in this hand
I'm gonna take all my love for Staten
Island I'll put it in this hand and I'm
put it together that's how much I love
staying so if I can take your love and
put it in this hand and match it up with
my other hand with my level of love
that's a big level of love so Ivy did
you think there'll be a sequel you think
snowballs gonna get his own movie after
this I think if you really like snowball
and you really like the movie and you
tell your friends to go see the movie I
think that snowball may get another
movie after this awesome how does that
sound
and guess where you know a snowball
might film their movie
whoo let's go first
you